hello america i'm mark levin and this is
life liberty and levin and we're going
to do something here that i don't think
is
typically done on television not even on
this program
before i bring on our two great guests
congressman jim jordan and professor
paul kengor
i want to have a little chat with you
look what's going on in our school
systems
look at the abuse our children are
taking
we have federal bureaucrats whether
they're medical bureaucrats or
educational bureaucrats
telling our children that they're going
to wear masks even though the science
doesn't support it in the least
even though what the science does show
us it's having a incredibly dilatory
effect on the psychology of that
generation
if we don't defend our children and we
don't stand up for our children then
what use are we
we didn't turn our children over to the
government we didn't turn them over to
school systems we didn't turn them over
to the teachers unions
and that's what i want to talk about
briefly this evening
american marxism i want to thank you
well over 600 000 copies sold
in a little over two weeks it's not
because my name's on this
it's not because i'm on fox or on radio
there's a lot of people on fox on radio
were books
and so forth why is this a runaway
bestseller it's not because of me it's
because of you
it's the contents of the book american
marxism
and at the end of the book the last
chapter i have an entire section called
we choose liberty
and there's a section within that
section called education
now we need to address this i am
thrilled that parents are starting to
show up in numbers
at school board meetings but they're
abused at these school board meetings
the entrenched
unions the entrenched educational
bureaucracy and administrators
the the school board members this cabal
they have no intention of doing what we
demand we spend hundreds of billions of
dollars a year for these institutions
they call it public education
yet we have no say on anything that
takes place we don't even have
transparency
well that's got an end and i got a plan
i've got a plan and it's not just for
parents
it's for those of us who care about this
country it's about taxpayers
it's about grandparents it's about all
of us whether you have children or not
and it's this couple of the things
generally
we need to adopt the the strategies of
the left in some respects they have the
boycott divestment sanctions movement
that is an anti-semitic movement
intended to destroy the state of israel
well we don't intend to do that
hardly but we can use boycott divestment
and sanctions too against institutions
that are undermining our country
and destroying the minds of our children
this bds movement
we can apply it against school systems
more importantly we can apply it against
the national education association the
american federation of teachers
and their state and local affiliates
what else can we do
we have the power of the freedom of
information act in every state
we ought to be using that act in numbers
hundreds of people in every school
district should be filing freedom of
information act request for what
how do they hire teachers how do they
promote teachers what exactly is in this
contract that they have with the
teachers union
you can follow the the the texts and the
emails and other forms of communications
of the union representatives teachers
in these schools assuming those
computers and laptops and telephones
have been given to them or have are
being released by them
by the school system that's covered by
foia too
it's time to dig in not just to come in
from the outside and protest
i'm all for it but it's time for us to
get tactical
in what we do how are these budgets
decided
how are these budgets decided these
school board meetings
they have these these executive sessions
why are they having executive sessions
what's discussed in the executive
sessions
and ladies and gentlemen lawsuits can be
brought
obviously they're expensive but they're
legal groups throughout the country i
have
links and contacts throughout the last
chapter of the book
what the civil rights act in 1964
amended education amendments in 1972
your children are not supposed to be
subjected to a hostile educational
environment
that preaches that indoctrinates about
racial stereotypes there's some of these
suits going on now they ought to be all
across the country
offense we need to become litigious just
like they are
what else well ladies and gentlemen if
your kid
is being taught by a teacher who is
teaching them
marxism and louis farrakhanism dressed
up as critical race theory
you go into that school board and you
tell them or better yet the principal
i don't want my kid being taught by that
teacher period
what kind of training materials are
being given to the teachers you have a
right to foil that information and get
it too
cloud and pivot overwhelm the system get
all the information find out what's
going on
but here's the other shoe that should
drop
many years ago when i was president of
landmark legal foundation we've been
wonderful president there
now and i am the chairman we filed
complaints with the internal revenue
service
against the national education
association and a number of its state
affiliates
a lot of them you can do this too you
don't have to be a lawyer to do this but
again there are legal groups who will
help you
it is time to liberate our school
systems it is time to prevent them from
being the play things
of these marxist movements in the
democrat party it's time that we start
subsidizing these movements
and the democrat party here's a
complaint that was filed many years ago
many of you may not know this but the
unions are required to file
a form 990 that is an internal revenue
tax form
and they are required to provide that
information
on their websites to make it publicly
available if they don't they're
violating the internal revenue code and
you can still
contact them and demand a copy of it and
what about that form they're explicitly
required
to provide the government with certain
political expenditures
that they're using so it's public to you
to know what they're doing with the
monies what they're doing with the dues
if all such political expenditures and
activities are fully accounted for and
reported to the irs as taxable income
what we've found at landmark legal
foundation it's not
you've indirect contributions you have
all kinds of
in-kind contributions that aren't
reported
political expenditures are not limited
to money transactions they include the
cost of using apart or hall any
facilities personnel
equipment supplies automobiles that are
not really supposed to be used for
political purposes
now how do you find out all this
information foia
how else do you find out all this
information the internet
a lot of times they confess to the
things that they're doing even though
they may violate the internal revenue
code
the time spent by an organization's
employees directing volunteer campaign
efforts
or appearing on behalf of candidates
must be accounted for by the
organization
if these activities are being subsidized
by general revenues mark this is too
much information
no mark this is great look at the
newspaper articles look at their press
releases see how much time they're
involved in political activities
where they're coordinating with the
democrat party or the republican party
almost never
or they're coordinating with other
unions and so forth
that is to be reported on their tax
returns and rarely is
the nea doesn't report we we recorded
political activity
irs form 990 but they're supposed to and
you go on
the point is you're trying to also show
not only are they not reporting all the
monies
of general operating funds they're using
for political purposes
thereby violating their tax status what
else
these expenditures demonstrate the nea's
use of tax-exempt resources to support
political activities
it shows the nea funnels general
revenues from its own treasury to state
affiliates which in turn use those funds
in support of political activities
you can look for this they have to
report every plug nickel that they're
using for political purposes
they're very sloppy they're very
arrogant
the other thing is on their websites and
in their press releases they tell you
about all these political things that
they're doing get copies that
information
compare it to their tax returns i've
said in this book we should create
community committees now in these
community committees maybe you'll have a
local account maybe you have a local
lawyer maybe you'll just have people who
are earnest and want to dig into this
start comparing what they're doing to
what they're reporting
the information's out there nobody looks
at it
the nea and its state affiliates must
comply fully with irs reporting
requirements as we pointed out
here's the conclusion irs enforcement of
the internal revenue code
enables the public nea members and
non-member fee payers
to receive accurate and complete
information about the nea's political
activities this goes for the aft
and all their state and local affiliates
the evidence presented in the complaint
that we filed we argued
uh is that they failed to disclose the
full extent of their political
activities and expenditures as required
by the internal revenue code now i'm not
going to go through this and read at all
you could probably go to landmark legal
foundation website all that said
you have enormous tools at your
fingertips
enormous tools think outside the box i
help you in american marxism at the back
of the book
this is just with respect to the unions
they have thumbed their noses at you
they said we're teaching critical race
theory whether you like it or not we're
pushing this marxist agenda whether you
like it or not
i'm sure they're working with the cdc to
require your kids to wear face masks why
am i sure that because they did that two
months ago
kids that shouldn't be wearing face
masks these unions are at war with your
kids they're a war with parents
they're at war with our communities
we're subsidizing the whole damn thing
to the tune of hundreds of billions of
dollars a year
we don't run our school systems they run
the school systems and who are they
you don't agree with them i'm not
talking about every individual teacher
i'm talking about the institution of
these public sector teacher units
they are the enemy of public education
they fight school choice in the inner
city
they demand tenure even for teachers who
shouldn't get it
they demand pay raises even when they're
not working and i could go down the list
now i know i'm not going to be the most
popular individual in the world when it
comes to teachers but i want teachers to
understand
i'm not attacking you many of you don't
even want to be associated with these
unions
what does joe biden want to do he wants
to get rid of right to work laws so in
every state every state
these public sector employees are
unionized and individual teachers can't
break free from them
my point is there's a lot we can do
there is a lot with litigation with
foia with protests with the internal
revenue service there is a lot we can do
and getting those cameras in the
classrooms that is critical the next
time that contract comes up with the
teacher union
you want those cameras in the classroom
and if they threaten a strike
and if they're in a non-strike state
they should be fired and if they
threaten a strike and they're in a state
that allows them to strike
then move your kids at least temporarily
this is a battle worth fighting in a
battle worth
winning and so this is just one little
area i wanted to discuss it's tough to
do it in 10 minutes
you can check it out yourself and
american marxism
but we don't have to take it these
organizations that we subsidize directly
and indirectly
they're supposed to work for us we're
not supposed to work for them
do you like the kind of education your
children are getting do you like the
fact that test scores are dropping like
a
like an anchor in the ocean do you like
the fact that they're being taught
radical ideologies
i mean incredibly radical ideologies and
that the teachers union tells them
you're going to have to take it whether
you like it or not and then your tax
bill comes every year
typically property taxes and you have to
pay it and if you don't pay it they're
going to take your home away
folks folks let's claw our way back
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else